first of all I wanna hang Great Britain
for the great leadership in assisting
Ukraine helping Ukraine improving the
security situation with the Russian
aggression against Ukraine Point number
two that every Ukraine from soldiers
from me as the fifth president of
Ukraine to president zalewski do maximum
weekend for providing the offensive
operation we should start in a very very
near future and definitely we do not
discuss when it's happened but we do not
wait in the visits weeks or months and
with this situation presidents we hold
the Mandate from Ukrainian people for
the Victory and we definitely count on
the great points you supply us
of assistance and support and I want to
inform you that your missiles storm
which is already has an extremely
positive use on the battlefield and from
all of the heart I wanna thanks you for
the leadership and give an example
positive example to our image behind me
we have a
trucks artillery trucks which was bought
by my charity Foundation all together it
is for the amount uh more than dozens
millions of pounds of my money together
with the money of the volunteers and
these trucks delivering from Great
Britain all together it is 300 tracks
together with a tank tractor together
with the generator radial tone Warfare
system and many many other things which
was immediately delivered from Great
Britain directly to Ukrainian troops
rising up the efficiency for uh
offensive operation and also I want to
attract your attention that on the G7
Summit in Japan that would be we count
on the results of these G7 Summit on the
new decision for Supply uh more than
military technology including the jet
fighter including the long-range
missiles please G7 member states follow
the British example and including the uh
joint decision about our future
membership in NATO which should be
adopted on the business Summit of NATO
this year
what do you make of the Russian response
to the British help and the help from
the other Europeans that we've seen over
the last few days they've said that they
have an extremely negative view of the
Storm Shadow missiles but they don't
think it's actually going to make a
difference on the battlefield what do
you think
definitely great difference and we now
have already the proof of that uh Second
position my uh
my personal advice uh for the as the
president who has a long negotiation
with Putin we can be successful only if
we do not afraid of culture and if we do
not trust with him and the great
response to any Putin blackmail would be
F-16 and I very much appreciate that red
breed and as far as I understand and
know start already the pilot F-16
preparation and training in United
Kingdom this is also a vital signal for
Creative the global jet fighter
Coalition who need to improve the
defensive and offensive capability of
Ukrainian Armed Forces because NATO
tactics and I'm proud that when me was
created the new armed forces of Ukraine
we based on the nature tactics and all
nature tactics take into account the air
support and air defense Ukraine now do
not have an air support and the Jet
Fighter Coalition can return to Ukraine
the sky government and at least stop the
Russians Sky dominance during Ukrainian
after a celebration and that's
significantly rising up the efficiency
with that situation this week it is a
bite
and you obviously can't and won't give
us a date for when you think that the
offensive might might happen but when in
your mind do you think that is global
jet Coalition could actually lead to
jets in Ukraine thank you
we count that the Jets come as soon as
possible this is point number one point
number two we do not wait uh jet fighter
for launching our offensive operation
Point number three uh I can confirm you
because every single week I am on the
battlefield together with our troops
delivering assistance maximum weekend
and all on the uh military exhibition to
choose and buy uh supply for the armed
forces and I can confirm you the
offensive operation can start anywhere
any moment along the our over the
Thousand kilometer Battlefield with
Russia we definitely do not command that
that should be a shock for the Russian
troops and we do our best that do it as
effective as our previous offensive
approach
what's the latest in back moot at the
moment
save again what is the latest you're
hearing from bakmut I'm from bakmud uh
this is the hottest point now on the
whole Battlefield and the role of bakmut
is the changing the character of the
operation if uh beforehand until this
week we have a very severe defensive
fighting now we have an opportunity to
make a small but efficient counter
attack unfortunately this is we have a
lot of losses and casualties there this
is the very big pain
but at the same time this is a symbol of
brain and ability to fight against
Russia because Russia against promised
to take
10 months ago but 10 months Ukraine
demonstrated the performance is real
Fortress of Ukrainian defense I was in
bahmoud many times almost every single
week during the last 10 months I was in
bakmud when we delivered our
fighting capabilities in the year 2014
2015 and I had no doubt that despite of
the fact that Russian completely
destroyed ruin at all there is no any
tiny place without Russian Artillery
where they spent a lot of artillery
frame selling but Ukrainian more combat
Spirit Ukrainian ability of armed forces
uh definitely surprised the world
okay a Petro poroshenko former president
of Ukraine uh good to talk to you today
thank you for talking to us thanks a lot